esta mañana a cerca de 2000 personas han
intentado saltar la valla de melilla a
uno de los enclaves españoles limítrofes
con omar huecos según la delegación del
gobierno español en esta ciudad habrían
logrado acceder al territorio
491 personas en su mayoría procedentes
de áfrica sub-sahariana cabe recordar
que son personas que huyen de la guerra
y de la miseria que azota sus países por
otra parte la asociación marroquí de
derechos humanos y otros colectivos
sobre el terreno denuncian haber sido
testigos de cantidad de devoluciones en
caliente por parte de la policía
española esto es la expulsión inmediata
de los recién llegados sin a seguir el
procedimiento y sin atender las demandas
de protección internacional y ésta es
desde hace muchos años una realidad
recurrente en la frontera de hecho hace
precisamente casi un año se produjo en
ceuta una de las entradas más
multitudinarias de la historia de la
frontera sur y la policía español
expulsó y caliente a miles de personas
entre ellas muchos menores de edad
también hoy según la asociación marroquí
de derechos humanos a cerca de 200
personas han sido detenidas tras
intentar saltar la valla y no
conseguirlo y han sido trasladadas a un
centro de detención en la ciudad de
nador y también hay 31 heridos
hospitalizados en esta misma ciudad
marroquí por otra parte fuentes sobre el
terreno aseguran que la policía marroquí
estaría ejecutando redadas en todos los
montes que se encuentran cerca de la
frontera española donde están los
campamentos de migrantes que están
esperando una oportunidad para intentar
cruzar la frontera